サッブパパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ サチッッタパリオダパナン エタングブッダンササナナン
ナモタッサバガワト アラハト サマーサンブッダッサ ナモタッサバガワト アラハト サマーサンブッダッサ ナモタッサバガ
ワト アラハト サマーサンブッダッサ サッブパパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ サチッッタパリオダパナン エタングブッダンササナナン
カンティ パラマン タポ ティティンカ ニンボナン パラマン ワダンティ ブッダ ナヒ パンバジト パローパガテ
ィ シャマノッティ パラム ヴィータヤント アヌーパワド アヌーパガト パティモンケチャ サンワロ
マッタンユタチャ バントス ミン パンタンチャ サヤナアサナン アディチンテチャヨーゴ エタングブッダンササナム
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
生きとし生けるものの悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
生きとし生けるものの願いごとが叶えられますように
生きとし生けるものにも悟りの光が現れますように
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
仏法僧の御加護により
慈悲の瞑想の力によって
今地球に起きているこのウイルスのテロ行為が早く収まりますようにと
皆様も私も祈願いたしましょう
サードゥサードゥサードゥ
えっと 今日のまあ あまり時間無駄に使わないで
さっさとテーマに入りたいと思います
あの佐藤哲郎さんも間に入って
もしかするとカメラの速度で音声だけになるかもしれませんが
あの協力してくれることを期待しています
では 今日のテーマはブッダのハラスメント対策
それについてちょっと紹介的な基本的なところはいかがですかね
哲郎さん どういう気持ちでこういう
テーマを作ったのかどうか
なんだっけ？ちょっと忘れちゃったとこもあるんですけど
まあちょっとあの 最近のその傾向として
ハラスメントっていう風な形であのいろいろな社会問題になることが結構多いというか
いろんなところでそういうハラスメントになっていて
なんか言葉として使われすぎのような感じもするんですけど
でもやっぱりそのハラスメントって言葉ができた
使われることで これまでなんかみんなが我慢してたとか
あとはなんか表に出なかった
いろんな世の中の矛盾とか
そういう悪い慣習とか
そういうものが浮き彫りになったところもあるので
それをどういうふうに仏教的に考えたらいいのかなっていうところはちょっと聞いてみたところですね
はい ありがとうございます
はい そこで私にとってはちょっと問題が起こるんですよ
このハラスメントということは
この仲間内で起こる性格の悪いところなんですよ
だから私はパーリ経典でお釈迦様がどう対応すれば対応したのかっていうところを参考にして喋らなくちゃいけないんですね
で パーリ経典ではこの仲間内でそうやって性格悪くて喧嘩したケースというのは一個しかないんですね
それは別な話で ハラスメントではなくて議論
異論の戦いでしたからね
ですから このちょっと困るところなんです
それは だから現代やるハラスメントっていうのは
仲間内で起こるいじめなんですね
だから 例えばある学校と別な学校がお互いやり喧嘩しちゃうと
それだったら組織 2つだからね
それだったら仏教的にこういうしなさい
こういうしなさいということは
話し合ってみなさいとかね
議論してくださいということはできますけど
だから 夫婦同士でね 男は女を
奥様はいじめる 奥様を旦那さんがいじめると
これは仲間同士だから
なんか議論しなさいというところは成り立たないんですね
そういうことで ちょっとできるだけ苦労していろいろ考えておきますが
えっと 要するにテーマを変えてみると
仲間がいかに平和で仲良し
明るく互いに心配し合って
思いやりがあって生きるのでしょうかっていうことに変えれば
簡単に仏教的な答えになるんですね
だからハラスメントはどんな種類ですか？どうあれやこれやと分析したっても
私はあまり時間の無駄やと思いますね
ハラスメントという言葉
この日本語でいじめでしょうかね
英語ではbullyという言葉がありますけどね
あの 自分の国ではね 大学生が新入生が入っちゃうと勝手にいじめちゃうんですね
それはもう法律も道徳もおかしくて
最近エスカレートしていますけどね
だからそういうもう仲間同士の喧嘩というかね
これはもうあまりうまくいかないんですね
その組織がね 学校でいじめがあると
本当に全体的な教育もうまくいかないということになるんですね
だから仲間同士 仲間だからお互いに思いやりがあって
心配し合って生活するべきですけど
なかなかなかなか人間にそれはできない場合もありますからね
人間というのは本当に面白いことは不完全ですね
誰も認めないね それは
それ認めればそんなに大きいことじゃない
問題ではないと思いますけどね
だからいくら理論あってもね
あの うまくいかないんですね
実際は では早速あの 時間も省略しなきゃいけないので
まあ私がちょっと分析してみたんですけど
それを出してみます あのテーマ 1 はこの嫌がらせ
この被害者の立場ですね
まだ文章を訂正して直してないんだから
明らかにハチャメチャな愚痴とか出てくると思います
例えばね 私は嫌がらせを受けているという自覚がないならば
相手が何を言っても嫌がらせが成り立ちません
例えば兄弟 お互いいじめたり
蹴ったり 振ったり 悪口言ったり
もうひどいこと言ったりもするでしょ
全然時々いじめられてないっていう感じでやる場合は全然問題ないんです
ただもうじゃれているだけになっちゃうんですね
もしかするとじゃれていたっても
ちょっと蹴ったりすると痛いしね
まあそれであっても 蹴られた側はなんとも思わないし
もうできることならもうやり返して
それでまあ そういうこともあります
だから夫婦同士で喧嘩する場合でも
まあいじめられてないという気持ちがあったら
ただの夫婦喧嘩で終わっちゃうんですよ
だから必ず必要なのは
この嫌がらせを受けた人が私はやられているんだっていう落ち込む気持ちにならなきゃ
これは成り立たないんですね
で 次 このいじめられているという妄想に悩んでる
病んでるならば 丁寧な挨拶さえも嫌がらせだと認識する可能性もありますね
悪いことはそれなんですよ
相手がすごくお機嫌いかがでしょうかとかね
お茶いかがでしょうかという丁寧な言葉しても
まあこの人はいつでも私をいじめられているんだからという病気があったら
妄想があったら あの言葉もまた嫌なことを言ってるんだっていう風に落ち込んだりはするんですね
それで普通の人は気分次第で被害者気分になったり
ならなかったりもしますね
そこで一般の人々の場合は
もう誰にだって経験あると思いますけど
まあ自分が嫌がらせを受けているとかこともあるし
加害者になる場合もあるし
もうバラバラ 一般の人々はそれであの回転するんですね
だから一方的に私は嫌がらせを受けているんだという風に歌うんじゃなくて
自分も結構嫌がらせをやってるんですね
だから両方考えなくちゃいけないんですね
嫌がらせを受けてる 受けてる
被害者 被害者 あなたはどうですかと
あなたも自分の人生見たら
相当嫌がらせやってるでしょうね
だから人間っていうのは
被害者 加害者ももうぐるぐるぐるぐる回っちゃうんですね
そこで加害者になったところだけで引っかかって
その餌を釣り餌を食っちゃって
もうもうもうもうかな
なんて言いますか この苦労したっても
それはちょっとあまり良くないことではないかと思います
では 加害者の立場からこれ考えてみると
意図的に嫌がらせをする場合もありますね
嫌がらせやってやるぞという風に
2番目 嫌がらせをする意図はないが
相手が被害者気分に陥る
こちら普通にもう楽しくいろいろ言葉がかかっていて
もうあなた田舎もんでしょうとか
田舎の芋でただもうもう楽しくするための気持ちで言葉を言うんだけど
田舎の芋や言われたところでいじめられてると相手が思うかもしれません
ですから 加害者という人がそんな気持ち
意図はないんです ない場合でも
向こうは別な意味で取ることもありますね
で それから性格は純然乱暴で
わがままで 相手の気持ちを気にもしない人々もいるんですね
これは性格の問題で 喋ったら失言ばっかしで
お前とか何とかとか これやれとかね
あまり例えばヤクザみたいな方みたいに言葉使ったりとかね
まああるんですね それで日本だけ見てみると
地域ごとにこの地域の一般的な言葉が別な地域で乱暴な言葉になる場合もありますよ
だからそれは私もよく個人的に知ってますけど
まあこれはもうこちらでは普通やと
まあ東京だったらこれは失礼やという風にね
そういう言葉もありますね
だから地方の人が来て
相手のことをすごい友達だと思って
地方の表現 言葉を使って喋ったところで
なんでこんな失礼な人やという風に勘違いする可能性もありますね
まあとにかく正確な乱暴な人は
本当に相手をいじめる気持ちがあるかないかわからない
ただわがままですね 自分の感情で一方筋で生きてみようとするんですね
それで社会周りには結構迷惑になる場合がありますね
はい それで被害者加害者の問題が無事完結に解決しましたっていうことは勝手に判断して
で ハラスメントの種類
1は言葉の嫌がらせですね
体の嫌がらせは犯罪行為として見なすことができます
体でいじめる場合は これは犯罪行為なんですね
言葉のいじめはあまり警察に訴えることができないんですね
だから 種類といっても 1種類しかないんですね
で 体の嫌がらせっていうのは暴力ということになりますからね
それから出版 放送 ネット
電話 デモなどはあるんですね
これも相当あの ハラスメントなんですね
例えばデモっていうのは当然ハラスメントでしょ
だからそれがけしからん
やめなさいと言えないね
やっぱり反対デモやらなくちゃいけないとか
やらなくちゃいけないんですよ
だからそれも考えてほしいんですね
一概に悪いことでもないんですね
で 国連の前でいろいろデモをやったりとかね
日本のなんだらかんたらの方
四角い建物 なんて言いますか
国会議事堂 で そこら辺でデモをやったりとかね
まあそれもある程度でハラスメントなんですけど
それで例えば政府は国民が嫌
賛成しないことをやると
相当政府をハラスメントしない限りは気にもしないんですね
だって完全に守られてるんだから
だから まあそういう有効な時もありますね
それで電話のいじめは結構最近ないみたいだけどね
結構ありましたしね もうとにかくいじめたい人に電話かけて
切る 電話かけては切る
電話かけてあげる あるし
あるいは電話かけてもうガチャガチャいろんなことを言うとかね
ネットはもう一番今もう王様ですね
ハラスメントの で 放送でもやってるんですよ
あの今は個人的な 今私たちやってるようなネットのプライベートの放送もあるんだけど
公の放送でもね ちゃんと政府から電波をライセンス取って
放送でも結構ハラスメントいじめはやってますね
これ微妙に巧みにやるんですね
いじめられているということはわからない
なぜならば いじめられている側はほとんどその放送を聞いてないんです
いじめる側 例えば日本はどこかの国に対して悪口を言うと
で 日本人だけ聞いてるっていう態度で
そうすると被害はないように見えるんだけど
日本人のアプローチが壊れますね
例えば あるAという国を批判する
そうすると日本国民がこの A という国に対してすごい嫌な気持ちを作るんだから
それも放送のハラスメントなんですよ
放送に もし正しいジャーナリズムだったら
そういうことはやってはいけない
道徳違反なんですね データを出してデータを比較してやる
て提供するのはもうリアリズムの基本なんですね
守ってないんですね  出版について説明する必要ないでしょう
例えば自分個人の場合でも
自分が宗教の本を書いていますから
どうせ世界の宗教は全て素晴らしいと言っちゃうと
私の立場が悪くなっちゃいますね
だったらお前黙っていろってことになるでしょ
だから条件付き 私は自分が語る仏教こそ世界一だと言わなくちゃいけないんですね
そうでないと成り立たないんですね
それで私は他宗教のことに対して言うことは
その宗教の方々はすごくハラスメントとして受け取ることはあり得るんですよ
あり得るではなくて あります
あり得るはないんですかね
だから まあ問題は放送局と同じく相手が目の前にないことなんですね
だから その場合は仲間同士のいじめにはならないんです
それはもう普通の議論であって
普通の議論で だからもし私はどこか他の宗教を批判したならば
その人々に権力は成り立ってますね
私が仏教を批判する それは普通知識的な議論になった方が
それはそれはいいことなんですね
そんな風に種類がありますね
それから原因を分析しましょう
ハラスメントの原因はいたって簡単です
私があなたに語るという態度なんです
私は汝に語るという まあこのちょっとニュアンス読み取れるでしょうね
態度でかいんですね 自分の
私という自我の気持ちが問題ですよ
私 俺 俺の話聞いてないんですか？と言うと
それも なんかよくないね
だからまあそれなんで
人間にある問題は 私がいるならば
あなたもいるのは当然でしょう
だから私がそれからですが
私が偉いんですね これは仏教でよく教える心理学でしょうし
自我という錯覚があったら
自我が世界一 自分が偉いと
この偉さっていうのは神様と同等にしているんです
仏教の神様ではないんです
他宗教で言っている全知全能の神様を
例えばまた他宗教批判になりますけど
あの聖書という どんな聖書でも読んでみると
態度でかいんですね 神という人の一方的に人をいじめるんですね
1 日 5回祈れとかね 俺が忙しいやという権利がないんですよ
ユダヤ教だったら 男ならみんなもう生まれて何の何ヶ月間とか経ったらみんなカストリしなくちゃいけないとか
イスラム教でもそうでしょうし
俺が嫌だとかね 例えばお父さんが自分の息子にそんなことやりたくないだったら
その自由がないんですね
それって明らかにハラスメントなんですよ
だから神様はもう堂々
正々堂々と自分が作った存在をもういじめているんですね
だから このそれは仏教では神様がいると思ってもないんだから
まあ置いておいて 人間が自我があるんだから私が偉いということで
私がいるならば 残念に他人もいるんですね
だから人のこと気になって
気になって この人がもうどうしようもないんですね
私がいないと 一人一人がもう1万人いたとしてもね
ただ空気のような感じで
全然問題ないんです だから俺がいるっていうことで
例えば3人の前でも喋れなくなっちゃう
緊張しちゃう場合もあるでしょ
一人の人と喋れなくなって緊張する場合もあるでしょ
足が震える場合もあるでしょ
それは私がいる 私がいるという考えなんです
そこで私が偉いなのに
話が失敗 失敗したら 滑ったら
ああ 偉い私が最悪っていう風に
神様と同じ部分になっちゃうんですね
許しませんと で 結局自己破壊になるだけで
そういうことで このいじめの嫌がらせの問題は
私があなたに汝に語るという
私の価値は何よりも上ですね
そう思っているんですね
だから 自分が言ったことはやってくれなかったら
あるいは異論を立てたら
やりたい放題相手をハラスメントをやっちゃうんですね
だからこの私がなければ価値っていうのは相対的で
もう流動的でしょうね
一時的に成り立つものでしょう
だから 自我がある人にとって
自分がつけた価値がもう価値なんですね
そういうことで あらゆる社会の場面でハラスメントが起きちゃうんですね
で 無意識的に働く この気持ちは相手を見下す
見下す 見下すんですね
はい これ私が偉い 私は誰も思ってないんですが
無意識的にちゃんと起動しています
これをパソコン用語で言えばバイアスな BIOS なんですね
あの WINDOWS 乗せる前に裏で働くプログラムなんですね
だからこのバイアスを改良しないと大変なことになるんですね
WINDOWS は問題があったら WINDOWS 会社があの客観的に直してくれるんです
だからバイアスの場合は
パソコンの場合はコンピューター作った会社が問題あったら直してくれますけど
バイアスは基本的に問題があったらどうしようもないんです
例えばバイアスね 情報を取れるようなバックドアつけておいて置いちゃうと
いくら WINDOWS がセキュリティシステムをしても意味がないんです
バイアスのバックドアから情報取れるんですね
だからそれはパソコン用語
そこら辺でやめて で 我々の心がこの我はいる
我は偉いというベーシックプログラムで動いているんですね
ベーシックプログラムには気づかない
私たちはワープロを使っていると
これは WINDOWS
今10でしたっけ？今 WINDOWS 10使っても全然気にもしない
ワープロの機能だけに集中するんです
ワープロに問題があったら
ワープロ ワードに文句を言うんです
その問題は WINDOWS の問題かも
でも WINDOWS に文句言わないで
このワードが本当にもうあれやこれやとかね
例えばワードプログラムでパーリーゴーのフォントは打てないんですね
これけしからんですね
で だからこれ WINDOWS の問題かワープロ問題か
私もよくわかりませんだけど
別なプログラム使っちゃうと打てますからね
そこでペーストしなくちゃいけない
はい それで私たちはとても簡単に人を見下すということは
本能みたいに簡単なんですね
だからこのそれが原因ですね
だから解決策に行きましょうか
至って簡単 私がいるだったらあなた見る
私イコールあなたなんです
そう言えば思えば そうすると心の問題は私が偉いっていう問題がなんとか緩和しますね
私が偉いんだけど 私イコールあなただからしょうがないな
こいつも偉いやと だから気をつけましょうということになるんですね
そんなことを言ったのは
まあ自我をなくすことは
仏道で瞑想して智慧開発しない限りは
自我の錯覚はなくせない
そこまで人間苦しむ必要ありますかね
苦しむ必要はないんですね
例えば あの COVID 19 のウイルスが薬を作るまで
ワクチンを作るまで放っておこうと
どうします？誰も誰もそうする
人類は死んでしまいますよ
だってそちらには半年や 1年ぐらいかかりますから
あのワクチンを作るまでは
だからワクチン作ろうか作らないかどうでもいいんだから
我々は CОВＩＤ19 のウイルスをもう撃退する対策を練らなくちゃいけないんですね
そういうわけで 仏教も同じで
自我をなくすまでしょうがない
だからもう私は人をいじめるとハラスメントでやると言っちゃうと
もう世界は成り立たないんですね
だからその対策として
私イコールあなたということを考えたんですね
命の権限として皆平等で
対策だと  対等だと  対等だと
理性  これは理性ですね
うん 理性のある人は知るべきです
だから我々はね 獣じゃないんだから
人間だから理性あるでしょうに
まあ育てなくたっても
やっぱり理性の種があるんです
それ使った方がいいんですよ
全ての生命は対等であると
だから自分が偉いって思っても
そうすると自分が偉いという気持ちが全然問題なく
もう何か消えてしまうんですね
だから皆様は全ての生命は平等だ
平等だとかね 特に日本文化ではね
それは実行しやすいんですよ
だってワンちゃんでしょ
猫ちゃんでしょ だからどちらでもちゃんかちゃんかさんかなんだらかんだら入れちゃいますから
まあその気持ちでしょうね
その気持ちはもうちょっと真面目に受け取ったらね
ゴキブリちゃんとかね
カエルちゃんとかね 全ての生命にそれをつけてみれば
みんな対等で平等ということは
あの実践できます できますよ
これ 日本文化を使っちゃうとかなりやりやすいんですね
面白いことは ハラスメント大きい社会問題になっているのは日本なんです
どういうことか 私はもうわからない
そのように思わない人は学んで実践するべきですよ
今まで思わなかったならば
早くこの事実を学んでくださいと言わなくちゃいけないんですね
神ではなく 自己の業が業が命を構成すると理解すれば
人は人を見下す 見下すことはしない
神が人間を創ったというと話にならないんですよ
だって神が人間を創ったと見たところで
人間は上下関係激しい
対立する 喧嘩する 戦争する
神には選民すらいる 選ばれた人すら
だからこれは差別の大元なんですよ
しかし 各生命の行為によって生命の運命は回転するんだと言ったら
業の話なんです だから業は差認める
差がありますよ だって行為が違うんだから
誰のせいでもない 私はあなたと差があるならば
私の行為の結果でどうしようもない
私は試験落第したら あの試験出した人々のせいではなくて
私は勉強しなかったせいなんですね
だから試験をやった組織を恨んでいても
僕 あのなんて火炎瓶持って投げたっても
これ意味がないんです
ですから お釈迦様の言葉で言えば
全ての生命は業を相続して
業に作られて 業に生まれて
業に創造されているものであると理解すれば
みんなすごく気をつけて
相手のことをすごく思いやりがあって生活することになりますね
はい 次 あの 私は体のハラスメントを扱ってないんです
それはもう扱う必要すらないんだ
それは犯罪です どうしようもないんです
そこまで何かありますかね
明確なポイントやらなんか突っ込んでなんか反対的に言いたいものとかは
手嶋には  そうですね あの業
神 神を持ち出すより 業の業で考えた方が平等だっていうのは
まあまあ言われてみればそうかなって感じもするんですけど
まあ業によってでいうと
なんかどうせその あの自分の自分の状況は
その過去世の過去のあのやったことで決まってるっていう風に言われると
なんかちょっとあの それもなんかちょっと気持ち的に暗くなっちゃうというか
なんかみんなもう初めから決まってるんだみたいに思っちゃうこともあるような気もするんで
その辺はどう考えたらいいのかなという
それは私もないとは言えませんよ
だって自分がいろいろこれがない方がいい
これがない方がいいとかね
自分の性格に対してね
で 思ったりはするんだけど
それで でも今更どうしようもないね
昨日もあのやいさんと一緒にちょこちょこと録音したんだけど
録音してから聞いたらあまりにも高い音声ですごく嫌な気持ちになったんですね
自分の声に それで本当にそれ私の声かと安田さんに聞いたらそうですよと言うと
みんな嫌な気持ちで聞いているなと思ったんですね
だから私は個人的にこの声は好きじゃないんです
あまりにもハイピッチなんですね
私は大きくて喋ってるんだけど
言葉だけうるさい もうハイピッチですから
これ 自分の気持ちと音が合わない
今更声帯は変えられませんね
だから落ち込みは十分落ち込みますけど
一応落ち込まないことにしました
だって声帯は変えられませんからね
そういうわけで まあセットができているんだから
そのセットでね もうわがまま言わないで
これからどうするのかっていうことをね
このセットはどうやって使うのかとね
まあ考える だから私は結構冗談を言うのは
この言葉のトーンが高すぎだから
なんか冗談でも言って
なんとか雰囲気を和らげようかなという気持ちはあるんだけど
これ冗談はなかなか笑ってくれない
冗談ばっかりになっていて
ものすごく冷えちゃうんですね
で 夏だったらいいんだけど
はい 他ありますかね だからもうちょっと言いたいんですね
だって 業っていうのは
このセルフコントロール
自分の管理 自分でやってくださいという
この所有権 自分の手に来るんですね
神に行くんじゃなくて
だから一人一人が 例えば人をいじめたくなっても
これ自分の行為でしょ
自分には必ず返ってくる
相手が立派な人格者だったら
いじめたっても全然気にもしないんだったら
自分一人で燃えるだけでしょ
それでもう相手 本当にいじめ受けちゃって落ち込んで企んで何かやったらどうする？結局自分の行為なんですね
自分が結果を受けるんですね
だから一人一人に自分の命の操縦桿をあげてるんです
あげて操縦の仕方も教えているんです
すごくわかりやすく 怒り
貪瞋痴の感情を使うなよと
それだけです それで全て行為が善行為になるんですね
だから 過去の業で男になった人が今更女になりたくたって
もう諦めた方がいいでしょうに
なんで私は女で生まれた悩みよりは女で人生完成すればいいでしょうに
だから 生まれたものでどう生かすのかということがね
これはまあ社会マーケットの状況を見て
自分がどんな商売すればいいかと考えることと同じなんですよ
自分の品物に適切なマーケットが現れるまで待ってるんじゃなくて
マーケットの状態に合わせて自分を売り込む
そのように一人一人に自分なりの人格があって
埋まる人格は向上できるし
ある程度でベーシック思考パターンが入っているし
それも勉強によって直すこと
できるし で イカレっぽい性格の人も生まれるし
だからその人はもうすぐそれに気づいて
その人にはきついかもしれません
だけど長い間学んで学んで
その性格は治る 治る 治すことはできるし
だからすべて無常だから固定したものは何もないんです
固定したものっていうのは物体だけなんですね
私の生態と同じことなんで
これはもう生態は老いるんだけど
違う プロカ習の生態に入れ替えることはできません
そういう肉体のことはどうしようもないんですけど
心はもうすぐ変えることはできます
ですから 仏教とは学ぶ世界と言っているのはそういうことなんですね
仏教は宗教じゃなくて
人類に学べと言っているんです
だから 学ぶということは
学校の知識学びではなくて
人生を学んで 学んで学んで
人生を正しく生きてみることなんですね
そういうことで まあ暗くなろうとすればなりますよ
暗くならんと思っちゃえば
暗くならないで明るくいることもできます
とにかく業の教えはしょうがない
それは宇宙の法則ですから
業が 行為が結果を出す
物質の中でも同じ法則なんですね
行為によって結果が出てくる
だからこの因果法則でしょうしね
だから あのトランプさんが差別的にチャイニーズウイルスと言っているね
あれは人間じゃないと
これは差別用語ですけどね
この人は人間じゃないと思う
思いたいくらいなんですけど
テキストに彼が喋るテキストにありましたけど
コロナウイルスと彼が削除してチャイニーズと書いているんです
で チャイニーズウイルスと
だからこの際 中国をもう徹底的に攻めてやるぞという
だからコロナウイルス
みんな世界人類がテロを受けているんだから
それあの人もテロを受けているんだから
それに対応するべき人間がまとめるべき時
人間が互いに慈しむべき時期になっているんです
それはコロナウイルスが教えているんです
だからウイルスはテロリストとして来て
我々に何かメッセージを出しているんですよ
お互いに人間がもう国別であれでこれでもうお前偉い
お前悪い 我は偉いと そんなもん成り立たんやと
だからこの COVID19 というのは
もう本当にこの感染性というのはものすごい高い
前のウイルスよりも いたって単純に感染する
だから これ 人間が一つ家族のようにまとめられないと
これはもう退治できないんですよ
だから当然科学者は戦っちゃうし
戦っていろんな薬作るんですが
薬あれあれ これなくても
我々はお互い仲良く兄弟として活動するならば
まあ早くもこの問題を解決に向かうことはできるんですよ
その上でこの人は反対やってるんだから
まあそういうことで まあなんでその話したか忘れちゃった
もう だからこのすべて自分管理で自己管理当ててるんですね
だから他人任せにしてはいけません
何一つも あなたのせい
あなたのせいっていうのは
我々口癖に言うんだからね
ウイルスは中国のせいだと
中国のせいじゃないんです
そういうふうなことで
このじゃあ次にいきますか
はいはい じゃあ次にいきます
これ 言葉のいじめの場合は
人が喋っていじめるんですね
なんで喋るんですかね
人間っていうのは 音を出して動物もコミュニケーションするが
人間は言葉を持っているので
命に関係ないものをしゃべる
話すんですね 音を出して動物はコミュニケーションするんですよ
人間も同じことやってますけど
人間の音はには言葉になってるんですね
だから命に関係ないものまで喋るんですね
それはもう一概に悪いではなくてね
いいとこの方がものすごいたくさんありますが
余計なことも喋るんですね
動物の世界ではないんです
動物の間で喧嘩あっても
それは必要な喧嘩なんです
いじめじゃないんです
やらなくてはいけないんです
だって威嚇の声があるでしょ
これは必要なんです 人間の場合は言葉あるんだから
余計なことを喋るという問題があるんですね
1私が話す言葉は相手に本当に必要ですか？と
それ考えてほしい  2相手が拒絶反応を起こさず聞いてくれますか？と
私はこの人格者の喋り方を今説明しているんです
答え出してるんです 言葉喋るからってに喋ってわかんです
なぜならば 生命として見るといらん能力なんです
言葉なくてすごい元気で猫は生きてるんだから
ニャンという言葉にはトーンがいくつかあるんだけど
数えたって私はだいたい６ ８
程度なんです だからこの６ ８
程度の単語で頑張ってますから
全然問題ないんです だからこの
で 人間が大量に言葉を持ってるでしょうに
だから何でも喋れじゃないでしょ
これはなんかケタ線が原子爆弾持ってるんだから
まあ撃ちまくっちゃえばいいでしょという話になるんです
ハチャメチャ作って持ってるならば
勝手に持ってきなさいと
まあ貧乏になるのはあんた方よと
それはいいんだけど 使ってはいけないんですね
だから この世界がコロナウイルスですごい状態になっている
ミサイルの発射して実験しているんです
2番目は一番大事で 私が喋ることは相手が
例えば何か言いたいんで
相手が拒絶反応しちゃうと却下すると言った意味がないでしょうに
ですから 気をつけてほしいんですね
それも自己戒めなんですね
相手が却下しないで 拒絶しないで
最低聞き入れるぐらいはしてくれるのかと
3番目の戒めは 相手の意見
反論を聞いてみるお知識があるのですかと
自分が喋ったら意見が出してるんですよ
意見出しちゃうと向こうにも意見現れるんです
もしその人それを言ったら
なんだあんたはとか態度になっちゃうと
あんた異論するつもりですかと
それがハラスメントなんです
例えば 学校の教師が生徒に何か言ったら
生徒がそれに反対的な何か言葉言ったら
それとんでもないというよくないんです
そちらにもそれなりの意見があるんです
だからその意見も聞くお知識がないと
人に一方的に喋ってはいけないんです
4番目のポリシーは 私の言葉で皆が明るく明るい気持ちになるのですかと
自分が喋ると周りが明るくなるならばすごいでしょう
立派な人間でしょう 馬鹿にできないでしょうに
だからどんな人でも頑張ってみれば
頭が咲いている 頭がよく回転する人間になるんです
周りを明るくする はい
話す前にアイデアを整理整頓して話しますかと
すぐ喋ってはいけない
まずこれは喋りますと整理整頓しなくちゃいけない
これであの整理整頓することには時間かかる人もいるんだけど
しょうがない それだったらもうちょっと
ちょっと待って考えて喋ればいい
その分相手は待ってますよ
自分考えるという信号を出したら
信号出さなくても体から信号出ますから
何か質問すると 私は黙っていると
何か考えていると向こうは理解するでしょう
だからあの暗黙の暗黙でしたっけ？あの音
音のない時間 すごい大事なんです
相手も落ち着くし こちらも落ち着くし
喋る場合はちゃんと整理整頓して喋るし
そういうこともあります
私はちょっとすぐ整理整頓しますからね
それは仕事上の問題で
いろんな質問を受けますから
あの ちょっと待って 俺
5分ぐらいか 10分ぐらい考えちゃうと
ちょっと仕事成り立たないんですね
だから瞬時に整理整頓しますけど
みんなそうする必要はないんです
はい  6番目の戒めは 話す内容を支える証拠などはありますかと
証拠なかったら喋らない方がいいんですね
あるいは私の気持ちだと
私はそう思いますよ 私の感情やと程度ぐらいでも言って身を守った方がいいんですね
そうです こうですと言った
言ってはいけません それ証拠ないと
7番目 相手をしつけるアドバイス
指導 戒める言葉であるならば
自分にその責任と資格がありますかと考えてください
よくハラスメント起こるとこなんですね
会社の上の人は部下をハラスメントすると
上の人には指導する権利があるんですね
だからガチャガチャ言う前に
自分が本当にもう上の立場に立ったんだけど
その資格はあるのかと
資格なかったら資格あるようにしなくちゃいけないんです
例えば親が子供に喋るでしょ
で 子供がなんで聞いてくれないかというと
これは結局は親のハラスメントなんです
だから聞いてくれないんです
だから親はまず資格を取らなくちゃいかんですね
どう言えば どう言えば子供は理解してくれるのか
従ってくれるのかと だから
それもなく 運転免許なく運転するような感じでしょうね
言葉の運転免許を取らなくちゃあかんです
だから世の中で年上の人やら先輩やら
好き勝手に喋る資格はない
先輩になったら気をつけなくちゃいけない
我々仏教出家の世界でよく知ってますからね
出家っていうのは 上になればなるほど大変なんです
楽ちんじゃないんです
沙弥でいた時は なんてすごい世界で
なんだ楽しいでしょうかと
もうやりたい放題のことやっていたんだけど
何か間違いしてもさっさと師匠が来て
それをなんとか助けてくれる
信者さんと何か言葉を間違って喧嘩になったっても
師匠が割り込んできて
すぐ私を守ってくれたりはする
上に行けば行くほど大変なんですよ
例えばテーラワーダ仏教の宗派がありますから
宗派の監修になると もうものすごい徹底的に言葉に気をつけなくちゃいけなくなるんです
だって言葉そのまま放送するんだから
大変なんです そういうわけで
上に先輩になったとかね
教師になったとか 調子に乗るんじゃないんです
教師になるのはいいんだけど
で 会社で何て言いますか
上のランクに入ったとかね
ああ 係長になっちゃったとかね
威張った場合じゃないんです
上に上がれば上がるほど
謙虚にならなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから あの木のたとえね
木の実って実が健康で大きくなればなるほど枝が下がるでしょ
そのような感じで 稲穂がね
ちゃんと熟すると 日本の稲は下がりませんだけど
スリランカ稲は綺麗に稲
稲穂が下がっちゃうんですね
だからもう稲刈り時期だと
だから我々はそういう学問的に社会の立場として
いろんな立場 上になればなるほど謙虚で謙虚で
人に喋ることは気をつけなくちゃいけないんです
そこら辺の戒めがないんだから
こういう問題が起きているんですね
それから世間話という言葉もあるんですね
人は感情を言葉に翻訳して喋っているんで
ほとんどそうなんですね
何喋ってるか 感情を翻訳しているんです
だって感情に言葉ないんだから
感情って要らんもんでしょうに
感情は主観で 自分だけの世界で
相手に何の関係もないものです
しかも悪行為です それは言葉に翻訳して喋ると自分が悪行為していることになるんです
だから仏教で無駄話は悪行為なんです
あれは殺生よりも悪く重い行為なんです
重い罪なんです だって
例えば私は怒ったりして
あるいは例えばウイルス対策に対して
日本の政府のアプローチはだらしないとかね
勝手に怒って それダラダラダラダラ言っちゃうと
聞く聞く人もその怒りに乗ってきて
結局はこれデータ的に言って
そこでストップしなくちゃ
こういうデータだったらこうした方が良かったんじゃないですか
でもまだこれやってないやと
それで感情を入れちゃうんですね
結局自分たちもウイルス撒いてるんですね
怒りのウイルス 批判 非難のウイルスとかね
だけど知らんうちにすごい悪行為をしたことになるんですね
だからこの このたくさんね
1日例えば 1時間喋っちゃうと
だいたいまあまあ50分ぐらい感情無駄話喋ってるんです
感情の対話は争い 落ち込み
非難 侮辱 いじめ 嫌がらせ
ハラスメントの元です
だからハラスメントっていうのは結局は感情で喋ってる
理性で喋ってないんです
だから悪行為です 言葉のハラスメントやる人は当然悪行為しているんです
じゃあブッダの答えに行きますね
私はいない ブッダの安穏の世界
無常と因縁 これ このセクションは皆様にちょっとレベル高すぎに感じるかもしれませんだけどね
すべては無常の現象なので
すべて無常ですよ 無常でないもの何もないんですね
非難 侮辱 軽視 嫌がらせ
ハラスメントなどは成り立たないんです
ほんの瞬間の出来事です
瞬間に現れて消えるんです
すごい瞬間で 無常でないとそれはあると思っちゃうんです
固めて取っちゃうんです
これ妄想なんです だから被害者たちが自分の妄想で
無知で被害を受けているんです
たとえ客観的にある人 A
という人が Bという人は非難
侮辱する ハラスメントをしている
しかし その言葉というのは無常で
瞬間瞬間パパパパッと消えるものなんです
だから 受けた人がこの言葉を取りまとめて
聞いた人がね ものすごく
非難を受けたと その日でも覚えて
次の日も覚えておいて
無常なのに妄想を繰り返し
繰り返し繰り返し 常にあるものだと思っちゃうんですね
だから被害は自分の妄想の結果なんです
無知の結果なんですね
それは一般的な ちょっと時効難しいかも
これ仏教の世界ですよ
無常やということ しておけば
あ 終わったと 雨が降って止んだと
終わっちゃえばそれだけなんですね
なしならば たとえ相手が自我を張っていても
実際には自我がないんです
相手が自我を張って 俺はあれやこうだからお前はとかね
言ったっても お前も俺もないのに何言ってるのかっていうね
音だけ鳴れるとかね そうやってブッダの教えから考えてみると落ち着いていられます
面白いことは 聞く人がそういう無常やと思って落ち着いていると
相手が話を聞いているのかって聞かないんです
話を聞いてると錯覚を起こすんです
だってこちらの顔はすごく穏やかだから
それだけじゃなくて自分も落ち着くんです
自分も落ち着いたところでしっかり言ってやった
よかったというも返るんです
だから問題ないんです
こちらでもなんだ こんなことを言うなと
こんなこと言われる筋合はないやという気持ち作っちゃうと
これで対立しちゃって
向こうももう一度やりたいと気持ちもあるし
こちらもまたすごく侮辱を受けたという気持ちで悩むことになっちゃうんで
それで妄想の結果なんで
だから無常と思っちゃえば問題はないんです
で ここに五蘊の機能があるが
私はいません だから色受想行識って五蘊あるんだけど
それはずっと流れるんですね
なんかあの流れる水の流れ五つのような感じで流れつつ流れている
で 私はいませんと もう一つの方法にポジティブアプローチ
ポジティブアプローチのみをする
相手の怒り 憎しみの感情に怒りが収める
落ち着いた言葉で対応する
だから自分が解毒剤で喋る
これは結構難しいですけどね
仏教を学んでおかないと
仲良く仏教を学ぶと その能力は身につくんです
相手が怒って喋っていると
こちら反応しますよ ちゃんと
そう でもね これでこれでこうじゃないのとかね
しかし 自分の言葉で怒りに対する解毒剤が入っているんで
怒りに対しては慈しみ
あるいは理解 理性ですね
他の感情に対しても 嫉妬で喋っている場合でも
嫉妬をなくすような気持ちで喋られます
だから嫉妬はネガティブでしょ
嫉妬はない 明るくポジティブでしょ
怒りはネガティブでしょ
怒りがなくなる思考がポジティブでしょ
だからそれにポジティブでいるぞと
だから俗世間的なネガティブ
ポジティブではなくて
仏教的に善悪の問題なんですね
常に善にいますと 自分の心を頑張ればいいと思います
できることなら 相手の悪感情が0になるポジティブ言葉を使う
これできるならばと言って
これは能力育てた方がいいんです
みんなに必ずできるということは
私はちょっと言えませんので
今ちょっと脱線してお釈迦様の一つエピソード申し上げますね
あるバラモン人の奥さんがこそこそと女同士で外へ出て
ブッダに出会ってブッダの話を聞いちゃったんです
その女性が バラモンの女性が誘っちゃった
夜中に夜中に誘ったら
もう全て真理がだったらブッダだけやと
みんな嘘ばっかしやと
知ってるんで 家に戻ったら
もうもう伝統的なバラモン系の家なんですね
普通旦那が知らない これは
そこでバラモン寺院のバラモン宗教のすごい大きな儀式があったんです
儀式の場合は もう男たちはもう今と同じく
もうただ偉そうに儀式の上に回るだけで裏の仕事をしないんですね
裏の仕事大変なんですね
料理作ったりや幼いものを用意したり
あれやこれやとかね だからそれは奥様がやらなくちゃいけないんですね
儀式は男たちだけで 招待したバラモン人と家のバラモン人が偉そうにやってるんですね
作ってきた食べ物を食べて
神様に差し上げて 神様に食べ物を差し上げる場合は
手を出したら奥さんが全部手に置いておかなくちゃ
何か間違ったら怒るんです
自分で行ってやることはしない
それはもうバラモン人だけじゃなくて
みんなそうなんですよ
そこでこの奥さんが何か何か出て
何か奥さんの方でちょっと失敗したんです
何か入れ物を何かちょっと落ちちゃったんですね
落ちた瞬間に彼女はナマブッダという言葉を言ったんですね
もう頭の中で仏教しかないんですね
これでなんだ 自分の奥さんなのに
この邪教の人を拝む 本当はブラフマーと言わなくちゃいかんですね
言わなかったんですね
言ってこのハチャメチャ立場がなくなっちゃって
自分の で 大喧嘩になっちゃって
そこでその人は怒りに狂っちゃって
お釈迦様のところに行くんです
ブッダですよ これは問題すぐったの
行って長い時間かけてブッダを侮辱するんです
ものすごいきつい言葉
言葉を探して探して侮辱する
お釈迦様はすっぴんで何のことなく聞いている
反対の言葉は言わない
なぜならば 本人が怒りに燃えているんだから
これケース 3つぐらいありますから
ちょっとごちゃになっちゃうと思いますけどね
何のことのを聞いていて
本人にも力なくなりますからね
自分が考えられる言葉
すべて喋ったんだから
もうそれからもさらに考えて怒鳴ったんだ
侮辱したんだから もうそれでちょっと黙ったんです
で お釈迦様 終わったの？終わったの？あの一言で終わりです
全部 さらにもう一つ言ったんですよ
あなたは私には別なストーリー
まあまあ それは置いておきましょう
お釈迦様終わったの との一言葉で
なんてことしたのかと
それからバラモンが聞くんですね
怒りは なんとか質問したら
お釈迦様が素晴らしいことは怒っている人に逆に怒らないことやと
それで世界は守られますよと
相手の怒りも消えるし
自分も怒らな怒りの炎で燃えないし
だから人が怒ったっていうことも
ブッダはいいチャンスにとるんです
俺 怒りを消して見せる
そこで世界にもいいことが起こる起こるし
相手も人格が直るし だからブッダはものの見事に行いましたけどね
私たちもなんとかなんとか頑張った方がいいと思いますね
相手の気持ちをゼロにするポジティブ言葉を入れてみる
嫉妬ですっごいギャーギャーギャーギャー喋ると何かゼロになる
何か言葉 言っちゃえばいいんですね
何もできない人ならもうノー反応する
例えばそんな言葉達者でもないし
仏教も学んでないし 漫画ならわかるんだけどとかね
そういう人にも方法あるんですよ
人が自分をもうハラスメントで喋るは喋るは喋るは
自分は感情を作らないで無でいるんです
それできないんだったら
私はこの置物やと置物にのようにでっかい人形やと
ぬいぐるみやと思ったら
ぬいぐるみは表情出しませんだからね
それで相手がもう嫌になってやめるんです
もう 何の意味もないんだから
大体人間っていうのは相手の反応を欲しいんです
人間というのは自分がいると勘違いしているんだけど
心の世界で心は波長を放送しているんですね
この放送すると受け取った電話と同じで
受け取っているかという反応が欲しがるんです
こちらで SMS を入れても
向こうは全く反応しないと何か不安になっちゃうんです
だから喋る場合でも 人を侮辱する場合でも
相手がどんな反応をするのかと自分が無意識で受け取っているんですね
その電波 アンテナに何も入らないんだったら
本人がすぐ辞めるんです
相手は電話が切れてるんだとかね
状態で番号間違いということになるんです
だから何もできない方々の一番便利で無ということがあるんです
いじめられないように
それからもう話はほとんど終わったなんですけど
ちょっと雑談的なお話になります
対話する時に 我々はいつでも対話しなくちゃいけないです
いじめられていじめられてるとかではなくてね
ハラスメントというところではなくて
ちゃんと対話した方が何でもうまくいきますよ
人に対話できない なぜならば感情を入れちゃうんです
あ ハラスメントですね
これを言ったらこれ感情ですよ
私はそう言ったら あの言葉間違ってるんじゃない？と言うんです
これはえ？いえ あんたこう言ってこう言ったでしょ
これ論理なしだってないんだと
私にとって冗談で 向こうはいじめることを忘れちゃって
もう別の話になる 普通の話になるんです
だから たとえ好き嫌いの感情も使わない
あの好き嫌いという感情は人間にあるんだけど
対話する場合は気をつけて好き嫌い感情を使わないことにするんです
私の意見はグループ A 相手の
これ対話のやり方 相手の意見はグループ B に分ける
だから自分の意見があるでしょ
グループ A 相手が言ってる意見があるでしょ
それはグループ B にするんです
別々の入れ物にいるんです
混ぜないことにする みんな対話失敗するのはすぐ混ぜてるんです
自分の意見に それで好き嫌いも割り込んできて
感情を割り込んできて
相手の話を聞いてないんです
もう喧嘩になっているんです
もう言葉の暴言と侮辱になっているんです
だから相手が相手に意見がある
これはグループ B 自分の意見はグループ A
別々の入れ物に入れちゃえば
それから人数によってグループいくらでも数字ありますからね
3人が喋っている 自分と
それで自分がグループ A
グループ B グループ C
そういうふうに分ければ
最後に主観を入れないでグループを比較して総合結果を見出す
混ぜない で 客観的にはこれでこれで
これはピンク色で グループ D もピンク色で
だからグループ A と D が一緒でとかね
グループ C は泥色で グループ D も泥色になりたいんだから
これは一緒にして じゃあ自分がどんな結論を出すのかと
そういうことで 自分のグループに入れてますからね
自分のグループは赤い色で色で分けてみるとね
では総合的にどんな色はよろしいでしょうかと
それでその色を出せばみんな賛成するんです
嫌がらせを受けた場合
自分に影響がない場合は無視する
影響は私に関係ないならば無視する
自分に悪い影響がある場合は
相手と直接議論する 相手の考えを具体的に取り上げて
間違いを相手が自然に理解するようにする
これブッダの立場ですが
理性がないと難しいんです
この場合はもうもうハラスメントの問題じゃなくて
組織 2つで 議論するときなんですけど
例えば私と私は仏教徒で
宗教の誰かと話す場合は
当然その人の考え方は違うんですね
私は喋る場合は自分が正しいと思わないんです
私の考えはグループ A
あの人の考えはグループ B
そうして聞いているんです
して そのグループ B にいろいろ
まずグループ B の中にある矛盾
あんたこれ言ってこう言ってこう言ったんだけど
こうなるんじゃないと
だから自分の箱の中のことを整理するんだから
真剣に聞くんです それでだからこういうことで
こういうことでどうなるでしょうか
ああ これ間違いです 相手が言うんです
こちら言ってないんだ
ブッダの対話を見ると
自分が間違ったと相手が言うんだったら
ブッダが一度たりともお前間違っていると言ってないんです
相手のサティ そうするといじめが成り立ってないんです
非難侮辱が成り立ってないんです
あら 私が間違ったと言ったら
それで終わりですから
そうするとちょっとプライド傷ついたなる
お釈迦様はそこだけ まあまあ別に言って直してあげるんです
それはブッダの仕事で
議論は勝ち負けの対立ではなく
対話対立ではなくて 事実を明らかにするためです
これは日本の皆さんも覚えた方がいいのは
議論っていうのは勝ち負けのものじゃないんです
会社で自分がレポート出すのは勝ち負けじゃないんです
事実はどんな どうなっているのかと
知るためなんです 真理を知る人は攻撃は攻撃に揺らがない
まあまあ これは仏教の話で
私は世間と議論しない
しかし 世間が私と議論する
ブッダがそうおっしゃっています
ナハンビッケロケントビューダーミローココビッケマイアビューティ
世間が来て私に攻撃してるんだ
私は攻撃してないんだよと
ずっと年間の説法でブッダが誰にも攻撃していないんです
議論してないんです 世間が議論作ってブッダと議論する
ブッダがその議論の間違いを見せているだけで
ということは 真理を知っている人にとってはもう主観ないんです
妄想思考ないんです だから成り立たない
何も一切現象は無常苦無我でだと知っている人には人に世間の非難
侮辱  知っている人はですかね
人は世間の非難 侮辱に動揺しないんです
非難と言ったってただの無常で
空きの波長で 自我があったら当たるんでいて
自我がなかったら当たらない
それだけ 風が吹いても山が動かないんですね
うん 終わり で 時間ちょっと延びたかな？ってもあります
いえ すごい早いです  １時間半弱ぐらいです
うん まあ一応早くしようかなと思ったんです
まあ放送ですから 生で聞くよりはね
なんかいろいろその話の中で起きた問題とかあるならば
結構ポイントがなんかその気をつけるべき
喋る時に気をつけるべきポイントっていうのが ７項目ぐらいあったと思うんですけど
なんかただやっぱりその喋る時って割とペラペラ喋っちゃうんで
なかなかそう７個  ７個チェックするの難しいような気もするんですけど
まあ全て訓練ですからね
やっぱり人間学ぶものだから
それは避けられないんですよ
だから いろいろ方法でこれを訓練した方が自然になりますよ
だから このまあ お坊さんたちの学校だったらいくらか喋り方を教えますけどね
あの だから学校の科目もそれもないしね
一応あの なんか議論大会とかあるんですね
でもまあ それようなところはもうちょっとしっかりすれば
喋り方ということでね
だから社会人になってから
まあうまく喋る喋り方についての本もあって読むんだけどね
社会人になったらもう脳みそが硬くなってるしね
うまくいかないんですよ
小さいから時からやらなくちゃいけない
あれは自分で実践修行しなくちゃいけないんですね
だから頭の中で喋る前にアイデアを見たらどうですか
アイデアを自分で見る
頭の中で 見てからそのままアイデアを喋る
この感情で喋るんじゃなくて
みんなアイデアを別にイメージして見ないんですね
だからイメージといっても
これアイデアだからね
この三次元的なイメージではないんだけどね
アイデアにイメージがあるんですね
考える時でもそれなりのイメージがあって考えるんだから
あの その考えるイメージをあるいは内容をちょっと外に出して
そこから喋るといくらかあの...あの
直りますし とっても訓練する必要あるんですね
それから言葉の使い方は別に学ばなくちゃいけないでしょ
優しい言葉とかね こう言った方がいい
こう言った方がいいとかね
それから言葉っていうのは
生きのように変化するもんだから
いつでも世間に耳を開いておいて
新しい新しい言葉が出てくると
フレーズが出てくると
まあそれも理解してとかね
そういうことも必要になっちゃうんですね
怠けて生活することはとにかくできなくなるんです
うーん それから喋っている場合は
相手を理解するかしないか
理解してるかしないかとチェックする必要もずっとあるんです
なんかお坊さん二人の説法を聞いて
で 一人がもうどうでもいい加減なことを言った人で
いつでも あんたは あんた方わかりますか？私が言ってること
あんた方 私が言ってることでずーっと聞くと気持ち悪いんですね
もう一人の坊さんがすごい真面目な
すっごい難しいことを言ってるんですね
言っていて あるセクション
アイデアが終わったらわかりますかねと聞くんですね
だからそれっていうのは内容難しいんだから
顔の反応で読み取れないんですね
その場合はわざとわかりますか？と聞くんですね
学校でもたまにあるとは思います
わかった？とかね 理解できた？とかね
それで楽しい対話が成り立つんです
だから普通の話の中でも
相手が分かったかないかということをチェックするというあるんですね
なんて言いますか 訓練次第で上手になります
人は生まれつきは完璧じゃないんだから
まあしょうがない しょうがないではなくて
学ばなくちゃいけないんです
その質問にはその程度の答えです
あと それからやっぱり最近
そのコロナの新型コロナの話でなんて言いますか
そのパンデミックであるとか
インフォデミックだっていう人がいて
要するに情報があまりにも錯綜して
みんなが好きいい加減なことを言ったりして
それで恐怖を煽られて
それでみんなパニックに陥っているようなところもあると
うん  今最近はでも本当にやばい状況で
特にヨーロッパとかひどいことになってますけど
今だから人間はもうみんなもう基本的には引きこもっていて
人と人との直接のやりとりはないんだけど
言葉とか情報だけがもうぐるぐるぐるぐる世界中を回っているようなとこありますよね
うん まあありますよねとしか言えないです
まあまあ一応私もこの情報ずっと見るんだけど
なんか感情でガチャガチャ言うだけで
誰も対策こうすればいい
対策こうしなさいではなくてね
まあインフォメーションする人々もね
別にまあ実はこうこういう風にした方がいいとか
そういうふうに出さないんですね
答えを そこで政府も困って困って
なんとかなんとかする
いい加減で だからインフォメーション出す人々は
個人的に自分なりの対策法
自分なりの対策法とか出した方がインフォデミックということにはならないんですよ
実際 これは本場正真正銘のパンデミックなんです
だからそんな冗談じゃないんです
これを手を加えないと
もう人類のもうかなりの人類が亡くなる計画でウイルスが来たんです
正しく対応しなかったら
もう新しい時代にしてやるぞという感じで来たウイルスなんですね
だから ウイルス自体もすごい簡単単純で弱い弱いもんですけど
感染性が強い ウイルスの形ですね
すぐ粘りついちゃうんですね
それで問題はこの気管支に入るんだだから呼吸困難に陥る
機械持ってますが そんなたくさんの機械を持ってないんです
どんな大きな病院でも
ハイポニー一発で呼吸困難に遭ったらどうしますかね
みんな死んじゃいますよ
じゃあこの人に入れて機械入れて
この人にはこの人を無視するっていうのはできないでしょ
手当たり次第 誰か誰かに入れて
もう機械終わりましたっていうことにするしかないんです
だからどんな理屈も通らない
だから結局はもう人間がまあやっぱりいい加減感情を喋るのは危険なんですね
ちゃんとウイルスのこういうことで
こういうことで感染する
だからということで だからこういう風にしましょうとかね
例えばこのたくさんの人々が集まることでもね
別に悪くないよ しかし
これ性格悪いんだから
日本でもそういうケースいくつか起きちゃったでしょうに
自分がある人 女性なんですけど
20代の成田で感染しているとわかって
ちょっと待ってくださいと言ったところで
何も言わないで沖縄に戻っちゃって
沖縄にそれでなんでそんなことをするのかと
だからじゃあ女性にだけ言って悪口言えない
政府は法律的にあなたはもうクオランタインやと
言うこともできるし クオランタイン法律はなかったならないならば
一応生ぬるいクオランタイン日本にもあるんだけど
ないならば あんたちょっと待ってくださいと
こちら命令大丈夫ですよと
ご飯やら全部用意してやりますからとかね
それもないんですね で
クオランタインはもう
もう調整に義務化しているんだから
自分の国ではね 飛行機から降りたらそのままザーッとクランタイに行かなくちゃいけない
もう話聞かない 誰でもそちらで全部
もうすごいごちそう  ３食もついていて
もう全部用意してあるんです
だから全然問題ないんです
最初は食事代でも取ろうという考えだったんだけど
これもやめちゃって もう政府のお金で無料で全部軍人がやってあげる
軍人がやってるんだだからすべて整理するのに文句言えないようにやってるんですね
だからクランタイに入った人々は
いやだ あんなものはと一人も言わない
すごく親切な面で見てくれたと
それでも人間っていうのは
自分をわがままで言いたい放題言っちゃって
言えばいいやと思ってる人々は
そういう性格で もうみんなにばらまいちゃうんですね
だから   どうでしょうかね
なんで世界中広げる？自分がばらまくのかどうかね
日本のケース そういうふうな一つ二つ作られるみたいね
ちょっと問題になったありますね
愛知県の人で 自分が陽性だってわかって
あの入院の準備してますから
ちょっと待っててくださいって言ったら
その間になんか街に遊びに行っちゃって
飲み屋とかで俺は陽性なんだって言って
みんなみんなびっくりして
でもね 結局その行ったお店の人も感染しちゃったとかっていう話もありました
でしょ だからいかに性格悪いのかと
だけど優し 慈しみのひとかけらもない
自我で威張るもんじゃないでしょうね
それは  その人死んじゃいましたけどね
ちょっと気の毒といえば気の毒です
ウイルスっていうのは
まあもういまだ勝手な形で最強の怖いテロリストと思わなきゃ
だからこのテロリストは人間を攻撃するって
あんた人間ですか？じゃあテロをやるという感じで
だからもうそういうふうに思っていなくちゃいけないし
一人だから 私がマスクけることが
私は我慢して自分を守ることではなくて
人類を 社会を 周りの人々を守ってあげることでもありますね
だからまあ 慈しみの行為なんですね
だからマスクの時でも
それは慈しみを持ってつけますと
俺が感染しないようにするぞという風な気持ち悪いではことではなくて
慈しみを持ってつけますと
言っちゃう 思っちゃうと
もうずっとマスクをつけて人と喋る時でも
買い物に行った時でも
丁寧に 活動できるしね
それで人間の性格が直るでしょ
そのうちウイルスは消えてるんです
だってテロリストの乗り物がなくなっちゃうんだからね
感染性という人は まあ年寄りとかは亡くなりますけど
若い人々はもう治っちゃうし
体力ある人々は治ったら
その人々はもうあれ持ってますからね
抗体持っているんだからね
そういうことなんで だからこの
これはもうインフルではないんだ
本当にパンデミックなんです
パンデミックやと真面目に受け取らなかったことでさらに増えたんですね
軽く見ちゃったんですね
中国を潰すためにいいチャンスやと思っちゃったんですね
今はどちらかというと中国の落ち着いちゃってますよね
周りの国はしっかり活動して管理して
言った通りに誰でもやって
中国でも韓国でも そういう国には真面目な
まあかなりディシプリンがあるんだからね
シンガポールでもね  日本はちょっとどっちつかずというか
中途中途半端な感じがしますけど
もっと中途半端なところあるんですね
だからあれですね 日本人が基本的に落ち着いているんだから
もうみんな別にもう落ち着いているという感じで思ってるんですね
誰かが来たっても大丈夫
そこら辺病院もあるんだから
そこら辺でそこで緩めちゃったんですね
この場合は この日本人
それに持っているお互い仲良くという程度ではダメなんです
もっとしっかりと人のことを
世間のことを考えなくちゃいけない
ですから 今 テスロさん言ったようなおじさんのキャラが出てくるんです
その方は亡くなったんだけど
もう初めからもう根っこから悪人というわけじゃないでしょ
普通に生活していた明るい人だと思います
でも ちょうど生ぬるい
この場合は あ これは大変
みんなに迷惑だと 私は人殺しの原因になってはならんやと
という風にすごい真剣に考えなくちゃいけないんですよ
はい そういうことで 感情的なニュースではなくて
我々を励める 励まして
この戦い この第3世界戦争に対してね
戦い勇気を与えてくれる
方法を教えてくれる情報が必要だと思います
そうすると 政府機関も医療機関もそれに耳を傾けるし
逆に医療機関はちゃんと知ってますから
その人々の話をね 広げればいいでしょうに
はい そのことについてそれだけです
はい ありがとうございます
じゃあ終了しますか？ はい
では 恒例の誓願で終了します
ドゥッカパッタチェニン
ドゥッカバヤパッタチェニンバヤソウカパッタチェニンソウカホントサンベピパニノ
苦しむものの苦しみがなくなりますように
怯えるものの怯えが消えますように
悲しむものの悲しみがなくなりますように
一切の生命がかくのごとくありますように
どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございました
はい はい それでは今日はネット中継で月例講演会開催いたしました
カンティパラマンタポティティンカーニッバーナナンパラマンワダンティブッダ